I mean here's the reality you got
Patrick mahomes you got two years in as
a starter he's one of the youngest guys
to ever win the Super Bowl MVP award the
youngest quarterback to ever do it he's
just getting started and as long as you
have him you're gonna be relevant
you're gonna contend and all these other
guys frankly are simply details right
the details around him the names are
gonna change there's gonna be a long
list of receivers and blockers and
defensive players over the next 15 years
the common thread is Patrick Lee Holmes
and Chris we are at the point where
Patrick mahomes deserves a second
contract he had to up a lot of the cap
space and make it harder to build a team
around him here is mahomes from Monday
he was asked at his press conference day
after the Super Bowl how much of a
priority is a new contract for you
before the 2020 season begins here's
what my home's had to say to me that's
that stuff that's handled with other
people obviously I want to be in Kansas
City for a long time I understand that I
also want to win a lot of football games
here and so for me it's it's kind of
letting that stuff handle itself I'm in
a great organization I have a great team
of guys working for me
guys and girls and so for me it's about
trusting those people finding the best
way to do it in order to have the best
team the best team around me and getting
that done whenever the time is right oh
no Patrick Patrick don't go down that
best team around me path don't do it
don't do it look look it's their job to
manage the salary cap not yours take the
Peyton Manning approach here right it
took Peyton Manning eight years to win a
Super Bowl but but early in his career
they didn't win one right and you got
your Super Bowl you put that in your
back pocket now go get paid and get paid
as much as you can
I mean look Chris they can reload every
year in the draft with young cheap guys
and they are uniquely situated to do it
you mentioned Andy Reed has an eye for
offensive talent they have found people
at every position in the draft more so
on the offensive side of the ball
especially at receiver they know how to
go out and get guys cheap you pay
Patrick mahomes what he is worth and he
is worth everything and then you build a
team around him I don't like it when I
hear the player talk about having the
team around him
look I'm not saying he should insist on
100% of the salary cap but but he still
should insist on more than anyone else
gets and it's uphill Chiefs to put the
team around him yeah it is you're right
there's no doubt about that now you know
hey maybe a Peyton Manning take took a
little less he would've got a Super Bowl
before his a beer players around him he
did he's Ted he had great players around
him his other reasons why it took that
long to get a Super Bowl my point is
they always found a way in Indy to have
great players around him and they'll
find a way in Kansas City to have great
players around home they found a right
formula there is no I'm just trying to
say that also though it is in the DNA I
think it wasn't me
okay I know there's other quarterbacks
out there I think it is in Patrick's
mahomes DNA a little bit to do something
team friendly I do I see that in him you
know again I always get into the
argument you know I understand you know
42 million dollars a year or something
like that that's what he's worth he's
you're probably asked for some sort of
number like that but if he got 38
million dollars a year okay
it's not gonna change his life either
but it might change his life and the
fact that he wants another Super Bowl or
two just because of it so I do think
there's a balance there as a leader of
the team you're the quarterback you're
being paid the most
anyways no matter what I mean come on
Jimmy Garoppolo stocked the best player
in the 49ers and he's making the most
money on the team so I do think you know
again I know I personally that's what I
want to say Mike I personally would take
a little less for a team that traded up
for me in the first round and you know
we've had some success so hey let's keep
this rolling I don't want to take a huge
blow to where I'm getting paid grossly
underpaid I still want to be up there
towards the top of the NFL highest-paid
player all of that but not necessarily
where I want to blow the doors off to
where I'm gonna make Kansas City really
have to figure out how to dance around
the salary cap and figure things out
that's all I'm saying
they've already figured out the toughest
part of this analysis which is finding
the best player currently in football
one of the best players in the history
of football so they have done the heavy
lifting all this stuff is just detail I
just
I firmly believe that when a guy is the
best player part of his obligation yeah
to his colleagues on other teams other
quarterbacks is to stretch the rubber
band as far as you can
Tom Brady failed other quarterbacks
miserably over the years yeah but he
hasn't failed himself he's sitting at
home with six rings go and screw you so
I make a lot of money other ways to
here's the thing yeah the thing he's
selfish in a different way right for him
for him the selfishness is bright I want
all the Rings right I'm willing to trade
the money for all the Rings which is
easy to do when your wife is a
billionaire yeah easier to do sure the
dak Prescott respond he was doing I was
married to her though you got to do that
he was married he would did do it before
he was married soon right I understand I
know but and you know what it also may
be a product of 20 years of abject fear
of Bill Belichick as I think that's true
I've been told I mean I mean let me
explain this I've been told that one of
the reasons he always took less is he
feared getting the drew bledsoe
treatment right he feared having so much
of a cap number attached to him that his
value as a player would at some point
fall behind his cap number and Bill
Belichick would rip the name off the
back of the jersey and say sorry Tommy
I've got someone else I've got oh yeah I
remember all the quarterbacks they
drafted over the years like one of these
guys is gonna develop and hey I'll just
use him because he's a hell of a lot
cheaper than you I don't think this is
Tom Brady being selfless it's being
selfish about getting as many rings as
you yeah right but but I think he was
afraid I that Bella cheque would get rid
of him if he was paying him too much
money hey Mike I know I think I've said
that to you before yeah I think he was
willing to be the good soldier but I do
think New England gave him the ultimatum
a few times - oh you're right I think
there was a little bit of both there oh
this is the only thing I argue and
they're not arguing cuz we know Patrick
mahomes the best and I want them to
strike it rich and I understand your
point also about you know it's your duty
because it helps other quarterbacks out
my problem is the quarterbacks are
already making enough the rest of the
team's not making enough I mean to me
that's why guys like Frank Clark
continue to bag on Jimmy Garoppolo
the day after this
Super Bowl and they're the first thing
that they talk about when they bag on
them and get on them is the first
comment is about the money and to me
that's where like defensive players are
guys in the locker room don't like
quarterbacks cuz like Frank Clark or
other guys he's going are you worth to
of me like Jimmy Garoppolo or two of me
or he's worth 11 million or twelve
million dollars more a year than me he's
looking at that and going insane so
that's my other issue with just a salary
cap and everything in general anyways
there's there's not enough of a middle
class and I'd like to see quarterbacks
start taking a little less to where it
spread the wealth to the everybody else
but I under I know that's easier said
than done when it comes to you
individually and it's your time about to
get paid and get a big contract and I
agree with you as it relates to
comparing a Frank Clark to a Jimmy girl
when it comes to Patrick my homes you
can't make that argument is its Patrick
mahomes worth - Frank Clark's yeah
probably that's 5 Frank Clark yes he's
worth all of it I mean we just saw the
ultimate display of his greatness down
10 points in the fourth unworkable
against a team and as you said yesterday
there is no one else on the planet
that pulls that off nobody right lady
doesn't pull it off there's another
quarterback who lived may I don't know
maybe Johnny Unitas if he was playing in
today's game but there the way that he
had to move and escape that pressure and
make the throws down 10 he's the only
one who can pull it off and now it's
time to get paid according what do you
think though like legitimately like what
kind of numbers are we thinking about
here like your 40 million a year right
at least 40 million year he's the guy
and and and what concerns me is when he
says things like having the team around
me it makes me think he won't push for
this one of these guys needs to have a
provision in his contract and it is
permitted under the CBA and I assume
it'll still be permitted under the new
CBA to have a provision that says I will
always make X percent of the salary cap
eighteen percent of the salary cap every
year I have a base salary and then it
gets adjusted upward or downward based
upon and you can say my minimum is this
and it's going to be increased so it's
never less than 18 percent of the salary
cap or 20 percent of the salary cap or
whatever it is
you probably crossed the line into this
little piggy ate all the roast beef if
you go to 20 yeah I think 1818 is a fair
maximum yes but as this cap keeps going
up and up and up that's the protection
you need that's why I think the the
Chiefs are screwing this up
Chris you sign him now yeah guess I
don't today no do not wait it's gonna go
up it's never gonna be cheaper than it
is to sign him right now yeah I agreed
with that yeah I mean you you feel like
you could get them for the low just in
general right now to a degree where he'd
just be happy to get some something's
you know substantial you know when you
start to get a bull I'm gonna get out
you're gonna offer me 120 million
guaranteed well okay yeah you know that
looks great right now yeah it might not
look that great two three years from now
and especially with your point with the
CBA
Mike I like your idea though with the
whole percentage play I think that is
the way to go
I would think Patrick mahomes would be
the first guy that could really get that
done in a lot of ways I don't know if
it's necessarily it's team friendly that
way too right I mean you kind of go okay
here it is 18% we know what he's getting
every year compared us you don't have to
worry about you know renegotiating an
unhappy player throwing out bigger you
know guarantees again to re-up the
contract things like that I just I
wonder if it'll ever happen or any time
here in the in the recent future the guy
most likely to do it
the owner most likely to agree to that
arrangement is David Tepper of the
Panthers based upon how he's blown the
curve for coach Matt well sure because
here's the problem here's the problem
and there's not supposed to be collusion
but there is and the management Council
which runs the league hates the idea of
tying player pay to percentage of the
salary cap so no one has done it and
Clark Hunt would have to go against the
will of the management council he may be
on it as far as I know it changes all
the time but you you put yourself in an
awkward spot where when you show up for
the league meeting in March and your
business partners aren't happy with you
you can sense it and that's part of this
game that gets played it keeps the teams
in line and it keeps teams from doing
something like what the Chiefs should do
with Patrick mahomes fascinating to see
how this plays out and you know what
Chris you
I thought of something as you were
talking earlier we got to go but let me
just say this this is the time to get
him because he's feeling great right do
it after the parade tomorrow right
he's everything's great everything's
positive he's gonna be far less likely
to play hardball if I'm his agent I'm
saying how they want to sign a contract
no now it's not the time to do it you're
too caught up
you're drunk on the euphoria of winning
a Super Bowl this is not the time to
make a rational business decision all
the more reason for the Chiefs to try to
do it right now
if they want to get this guy locked up
at the best possible price
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports